une année d'exception pour les fruits
rouges à la ferme de gally de
saint-cyr-l'ecole groseilles cassis
fraises ou encore griotte ce week end de
nombreuses familles se sont retrouvées
pour profiter d'une journée ensoleillée
tout en savourant les plaisirs de la
nature très agréable parce que ça allie
une balade dans la nature et en même
temps le plaisir d'avoir des des fruits
et des légumes qui sont locales de
saison iliadis niquille r&d grouazel
t'effraie
charmant plein le temps sec et doux
depuis la fin de l'hiver a permis des
récoltes longue et constante sur
l'ensemble des fruits rouges on a une
année qui a été relativement chaude avec
un printemps des températures qui ont
été assez élevé dès le mois de février
ce qui a permis une croissance et un
maintien des boutons floraux à la
différence de l'allemagne à où il y
avait des gros jets l'ena mais très
pluvieuse l'occasion pour lés parents de
sensibiliser leurs enfants au respect de
la nature et au plaisir des préparations
maison allait en ce1 elle va rentrer en
c2 donc on lui dit bien de respecter la
nature c'est très important et puis on
lui fait découvrir également bat de
l'ailé différentes sortes de fruits et
de fleurs qu'elle syrte des frets pour
faire des confitures ss à une très belle
année qui devrait durer jusqu'à début
octobre pour les myrtilles ou encore les
cassis cet été environ 2000 personnes
sont attendues chaque week end à la
ferme de gally